[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de Franz 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
Brasil muestra su mejor rostro cuatro
goles en menos de media hora definen el
resultado ante Corea del Sur La Victoria
va dedicada al rey Pelé nos cuenta de
ese catar nuestro enviado especial
Croacia apela de nuevo a su arma más
letal la efectividad en los penales
encontró un héroe en el portero
libakovic que paró Tres disparos de
Japón desde los 12 pasos y es el otro
clasificado del día cuarto se final el
reporte es ese dedo
Marruecos recupere sus figuras para el
duelo de mañana con España y Portugal no
sabe si Cristiano Ronaldo será titular
frente a Suiza así se cierran los
octavos de final tenemos análisis
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada contamos como siempre con la
presencia de Octavio saso periodista de
la emisora Blu radio en Colombia Octavio
bienvenido Hola Omar buenas tardes Un
gusto saludarte y también le damos la
bienvenida a nuestro enviado especial
Juan pupiales quien nos trae todos los
detalles de primera mano de lo que
ocurre en
Qatar saludos Juan
Hola Omar Hola cómo está Octavio Hola a
todos un placer estar aquí desde el
estadio nueve siete cuatro dedos a con
ustedes
y Brasil presenta oficialmente su
candidatura como favorito una goleada
4-1 sobre Corea del Sur cuatro goles en
29 minutos dejó Claro que los hombres a
ti te van por la corona con Neymar de
nuevo en cancha la canarinha muestra su
mejor cara en ese partido estuvo
precisamente nuestro compañero Juan
pupiales que nos trae el relato desde
dos a Juan qué podemos destacar de este
resultado
sin duda alguna la mejor noticia para
Brasil y para muchos aficionados del
fútbol es ver una selección tan ofensiva
volver a ver a esa selección con esos
cuatro delanteros como ocurre en el
partido contra Serbia otra vez cuatro
delanteros pero hacer eso ya en una
apuesta en unos octavos de final y que
salga tan bonito que viva el fútbol
ofensivo que vivan las gambetas porque
Brasil fue lo que hoy exhibió ya
Obviamente con el marcador a favor ese
tiki taka esos toques esas gambetas esos
regates me quedo con ese buen sabor de
boca de ver una selección tan ofensiva
Eso sí además de esos cuatro delanteros
vinicios de richarrison rafinha y Neymar
el papel de Lucas paquetá que hoy se
exhibió como ese buen llegador ese buen
acompañante en segunda línea que hay un
jugador que está en el huesca lejos del
digamos los equipos de estrellas de sus
compañeros pero que es una figura clave
para conectar con esa ofensiva una
figura clave para ti destacar muchísimo
ese buen nivel ofensivo los 80 minutos
de Neymar destacar también los cambios
que vimos por parte de títere de sacarla
el cambio en portería de weverton
destacar incluso también lo que hizo con
bremer el central de la Juventus quien
no puso por el lateral izquierdo
probando porque ese es un flanco que
puede darle problemas de cara al futuro
como hemos hablado Aquí Álex tellez ella
se tuvo que ir de esta copa mundo y
alexandro todavía es duda obviamente
también da buena noticia deberá Danilo
jugando con su equipo y digamos que yo
creo que la única espina que le queda a
este equipo es que rafinha todavía no ha
podido marcar en este mundial es el
único delantero titular que aún no ha
podido ver puerta hoy se notaron mucho
los esfuerzos por parte de Neymar por
parte de sus compañeros de conseguir que
rafiñe que igualmente está haciendo un
buen mundial que por fin consiguiera su
primer gol en un Mundial
Juan hoy Neymar ha recibido el premio al
mejor jugador del partido pero
definitivamente el funcionamiento
colectivo podríamos decir que ha sido el
mejor jugador del partido de Brasil
sí sin ninguna duda comenzando de nuevo
reitero con el papel de Lucas paquetada
en la ofensiva creo que a partir de ese
Pilar de Lucas paqueta Digamos como
armador de ese juego ofensivo da fe de
lo que sabe hacer este equipo de Brasil
también con orden en defensa orden en
defensa que aún así fue que quedó un
poco en evidencia con la llegada de
Corea del Sur que se va destacó del
mundo con muchísimo castigo después de
haber mostrado un buen nivel y después
de haber apostado Por jugar al fútbol y
jugar al ataque en la primera parte
mostraron otro valor del juego colectivo
de Brasil que también pasa por la
portería por Allison Allison jugando
como portero de un equipo grande
respondiendo bien ante las pocas
ocasiones que tuvieron los coreanos
pocas ocasiones pero con muchísimo
veneno en líneas generales efectivamente
un muy buen partido desde la defensa
hasta el ataque incluso hasta Dani Alves
volvió a jugar y Dani Alves que tuvo una
ocasión de oro para marcar a sus 39 años
en mundo obviamente gran papel de
casemiro un Pilar en el centro del campo
una selección canareña que entra a
cuartos de final conscientes de que han
dejado un buen nivel y conscientes de
que hay de ahora en adelante Cada papel
cada rival exige más seriedad y exige
mostrar a un mejor nivel obviamente aquí
ya endoja todo mundo ya habla de unas
eventuales semifinales contra Argentina
que serían en el estadio lusai el
estadio de la final
de doha nos vamos a Río de Janeiro
porque desde allá la corresponsal de
Francia 24 en español lo alegra sacones
nos cuenta cómo está viviendo ese país
el gran momento de su selección
mucho entusiasmo y aquí en el centro de
ríos de Janeiro con este resultado y
este primer tiempo lleno de goles parece
que los cariocas y en general los
brasileños se está reconciliando con la
canariña recordamos que hace ocho años
perdía en un trágico siete a uno contra
Alemania Hace cuatro años cubrimos aquí
los mundiales y no había tanto
entusiasmo se notaba un cierto trauma
ahora
esta selección y llena de jóvenes
Ah devuelto la alegría y la esperanza a
los brasileños que sueñan con el sexto
campeonato y además esos días la
preocupación por la enfermedad de Pelé
también ha dado una tregua Pelé parece
que está estable hoy ha mandado un
mensaje de ánimos A los jugadores ha
recordado todavía hay niños prometió a
su padre que iba a ganar un mundial ganó
tres todo el mundo en Brasil Espera que
Pelé se mantenga estable que pueda ver
su selección triunfar por la sexta vez
es un momento de alegría de felicidad y
de esperanza en Brasil que se acerca el
verano al cambio de gobierno y quizás a
un triunfo del fútbol
Octavio Vimos a Neymar al final del
partido mostrar una bandera donde
constaba que se le dedicaba esa Victoria
al rey Pelé que está en momentos de
salud delicados este tipo de cosas esta
digamos la necesidad de dedicar
victorias de dedicar rendimiento y
resultados a una figura como peleé
funciona realmente como una motivación
no puede ser más bien una presión extra
Pues la verdad Omar creo que que
funciona como motivación en este caso
precisamente por por el hecho de ser la
figura Quién es
Pelé evidentemente Más allá de ser una
Gloria al fútbol mundial seguramente
para muchos el más grande jugador de
todos los tiempos es seguramente un un
ídolo para la mayoría de los jugadores
brasileros y bien es cierto hay una
distancia muy importante de generaciones
entre Pelé y los jugadores que
actualmente están en la selección de
Brasil pero todos entienden lo que
significa la figura de Pelé no solo para
ellos para el mundo e incluso para su
nación como sociedad no Entonces por por
esa razón Yo creo que ellos están
motivados evidentemente por el hecho de
poder dedicarle esa Victoria sobre todo
porque el departamento de prensa que
maneja las redes sociales de Pelé emitió
también un comunicado previo al partido
apoyándolos a ellos Entonces me imagino
que estaba preparado el hecho y que
mejor fiesta que hacerlo con una con una
goleada tan contundente como esa y
mostrándole que evidentemente ellos como
jugadores y como selección están con el
rey Pelé en función de de su mejora de
su rápida mejor y que pueda celebrar con
ellos cualquier cosa en esta copa del
mundo
y el rival de Brasil en cuartos de final
será una Croacia que hoy volvió apelar a
su expediente más rendidor la tanda de
penales en ese partido estuvo nuestra
compañera Natalia Ruiz giraldo y ella
nos relata la victoria de los balcánicos
sobre Japón no hubo sorpresa ni milagro
japonés en este partido entre los
nipones y a Croacia fue la experiencia
finalmente de los croatas la que salió a
relucir en este partido que terminó
finalmente definiéndose desde los tiros
de punto penal un partido bastante
equilibrado entre ambos equipos con Los
japoneses que abrieron por primera vez
el marcador en este mundial uno gol que
vino sobre el minuto 44 de madera sin
embargo los croatas respondieron ya
sobre la hora de juego con un cabezazo
de perisic que gonda no tuvo como atajar
los dos equipos subieron oportunidades
cada uno de poderse adelantar de poder
conseguir la victoria pero finalmente el
partido se fue ya a prolongaciones en la
primera parte fue mitoma quien tuvo la
posibilidad de marcar para japoneses y
en el segunda parte de esas
prolongaciones fue Mayer sin embargo ya
el partido se fue entonces a los penales
y ahí pues fue la gran desilusión de Los
japoneses que cobraron muy mal desde lo
del tiro desde el punto de tiro penal y
también pues estuvo muy bien al iva el
guardameta croata quien atajó tres de
esos penales y de esta manera pues
acroacia se clasifica a los cuartos de
final por tercera vez
Octavio podemos decir que agotó Japón
sus argumentos su su Arsenal en la fase
de grupos porque hoy no se vio ni a esa
selección capaz de sorprender ni se vio
Con todo ese repertorio que había estado
mostrando hasta el momento yo creo que
no Omar yo creo que incluso mereció
mejor suerte en algún momento del
partido yo creo que Croacia resintió
sobre todo cuando el juego estaba uno a
cero
resintió la la capacidad japonesa Me
parece que quizás lo que le pasa a
facturas a japonés la falta de
experiencia en este tipo de definiciones
Japón tenía que haber marcado un segundo
gol en algún momento del partido cuando
incluso lo tenían uno a cero y y parecía
que lo tenían controlado Más allá de ese
gol de perisich que fue el mejor momento
de Croacia en el partido porque Croacia
con el gol de perisich llegó a incluso a
tener posibilidades de marcarle una
diferencia Yo creo que la tapa del
partido en la que hace el Arquero
japonés sobre el disparo aquel disparo
de modric que que termina sacando sobre
un ángulo pero a partir de Japón Tenía
mucha más velocidad tenía mucho más
juego colectivo pero le faltaba eso que
si tenían los croatas los croatas en un
momento Incluso le bajaron la atención
al juego sabían que alargarlo les podía
permitir tener futuro en el partido
porque iban a cansar a Los japoneses que
quizás su mayor virtud la velocidad y la
capacidad física y fueron agotando el
partido de tal manera en que me parece
que Los japoneses llegaron a la
definición por penales sin piernas y los
croatas llegaron llegaron frescos se
notó en los tres penales cerrados de
Japón que los jugadores no tenían
capacidad para pegar la pelota estaban
derretidos estaban destruidos los
jugadores japoneses y es una lástima
porque Japón tuvo la gran oportunidad de
me parece real la gran oportunidad de
acceder a a cuartos de final y de seguir
extendiendo el futuro nipón como dijo el
propio técnico luego del partido Así que
una lástima por un lado pero por el otro
la virtud de los billetes campeones del
mundo que siguen caminando
y como decíamos la jornada de hoy deja
definido un duelo de cuartos de final
entre Brasil y Croacia y le preguntamos
Octavio qué podemos esperar de ese Duelo
Bueno yo creo que después de lo visto
hoy hoy Brasil jugó un partido de otro
mundial de otro torneo incluso no
parecido mundial de fútbol por la forma
en como lo liquidó tan rápido y con
tanta superioridad ninguno de nosotros
por más de que sabíamos que Brasil era
el favorito y que la mayoría de de las
apuestas lo daban como el ganador del
partido no podíamos entender que en
20-25 minutos Brasil sacará tanta
diferencia frente a un rival que había
tenido muy buenos partidos en la ronda
de grupos Entonces el partido de hoy no
me parece que es una medida
necesariamente para para entender lo que
va a suceder más adelante y lo otro es
que un partido de este nivel entre el
Brasil de Neymar y Neymar bien Es decir
sano como llegó hoy frente a Croacia la
Croacia de modric pero con con más
espacios porque no va a ser Japón la que
va a tener enfrente sino una Brasil Que
prácticamente no que te deja jugar
porque su juego se basa en eso
seguramente vamos a ver un partido de
ida y vuelta con con muchas
oportunidades y un y un partido mucho
mejor de lo que le hemos visto a Croacia
en lo que va del mundial
y mañana se cierra la fase de octavos de
final con los partidos entre Marruecos y
España Por una parte luego Portugal y
Suiza donde estaba Por cierto en duda la
presencia de la gran figura lusitana
Cristiano Ronaldo y aprovechamos que
todavía sigue con nosotros Juan pupiales
para preguntar qué podemos esperar para
comenzar
de ese partido mañana de España contra
Marruecos que ha sido la auténtica
revelación del torneo
Marruecos una selección que aquí juega
como local es la única selección árabe
que sigue con vida en esta copa mundo
los marroquíes que son una afición muy
importante aquí y que aquí cuentan con
el respaldo no solamente de los cataríes
sino de los saudíes porque sienten que
están todos jugando por parte del mundo
árabe un partido Marruecos y España
cargado por una rivalidad histórica los
países vecinos los países además con
muchos nexos en España una de las
colonias migrantes más importantes en
las de los marroquíes dos países con una
relaciones políticas muy tensas
precisamente de la mano de la migración
con Marruecos la gran duda Sí en el
lateral del pez y uno de los mejores
laterales del mundo si él va a estar
finalmente condiciones para estar en
este partido Marruecos una de las
mejores defensas del certamen con
solamente un gol encajado con España la
duda es también por el lateral derecho
si es César espiricueta que para mí
Debería ser el titular si finalmente va
a superar unas molestias para estar en
este encuentro o si finalmente Luis
Enrique va a apostar por Carvajal Luis
Enrique que seguramente no repetirá once
para este encuentro no lo ha hecho en
esta copa mundo y la duda también pasa
de nuevo por la delantera versi Álvaro
morata uno de los goleadores de ese
certamen con tres tantos ya más alejado
de los cinco de mbappé si será titular
para este partido en el que la roja
tiene la obligación de redimirse después
de ese empate contra los alemanes y
después de haber entrado aquí con esa a
esta fase de octavos de final con esa
derrota contra Japón
le agradecemos Juan espero esperamos
tenerlo de nuevo con nosotros mañana
Claro que sí un placer y seguimos aquí
en doja
bien continuamos Octavio hoy veíamos
unas declaraciones del técnico lusitano
Fernando Santos que él no se había dado
cuenta inicialmente de la mala reacción
de Cristiano Ronaldo con su salida y Que
obviamente una vez que sale de él de la
rueda de prensa y logra ver las imágenes
confesaba que no le había gustado esa
reacción que naturalmente no no estaba
satisfecho e incluso deja en duda si va
o no va a estar cristiano puede Portugal
darse ese lujo de prescindir de
Cristiano o realmente no ha sido tan
decisivo no yo yo creo que no que no
puede darse el lujos me imaginemos que
Portugal quede eliminada sin cristiano
en la cancha lo que eso significaría no
yo creo que Portugal no puede darse ese
lujo por más de que haya un conflicto o
no le guste yo creo que además y
Cristiano Ronaldo y Fernando Santos se
conocen tanto han tenido tanto tiempo
juntos han ganado tantas cosas que yo
creo que eso se resuelve conversando y
hablando eh cristiano es un líder
positivo Más allá de que él
evidentemente neumar y se nota en el
mundial no está pasando bien no está
pasando un buen momento en lo personal
en lo futbolístico porque no va a tener
Club porque su carrera se está acabando
es decir No no es una reacción normal la
de Cristiano Ronaldo Más allá de de todo
lo que se dice yo creo que se puede
llegar a una a un acuerdo y Portugal
tiene que estar batallando hasta el
último minuto con Cristiano como sea
dentro de la cancha Supongo que mucho
mejor pero tratando de ayudar al equipo
porque porque es la máxima figura de
este plantel sin duda no y Porque además
ha demostrado ser un rival que que no es
nada sencillo no por supuesto entonces
tú tienes tú tienes a tu gran figura que
en este tipo de torneo se crece por más
de que futbolísticamente no haya este
rendido o prendido las luces como como
normalmente lo hace pero cristiano es un
jugador que te puede ganar un partido él
solo y todavía están esas condiciones
físicamente y futbolísticamente hablando
y él merece la posibilidad de seguir
peleando un mundial como lo está
haciendo Más allá de todo lo que pueda
suceder fuera de la cancha mañana
veremos si esas
posibilidades se
están realmente Octavio Muchísimas
gracias por haber estado mañana nos
reencontramos bien y nosotros
continuamos con una selección de
noticias del mundial la luz Celeste
retomó los entrenamientos de Cara a su
duelo de cuartos de final lo hizo sin
Ángel Di María ni su reemplazo papu
Gómez ambos afectados por problemas
físicos el técnico escalón y se debate
entre Lisandro Martínez y Leandro
paredes pero no descarta la recuperación
de Di María a tiempo para enfrentar a
Países Bajos
un equipo que sí podría tener a todas
sus figuras en ese próximo duelo en
Marruecos como lo decía Juan pupiales
hace poco se preparan a puertas cerrada
pero se sabe que están contando con sus
dos figuras principales aquí del Chelsea
y a Frank aquí mide el PC
finalmente la comisión de disciplina de
la FIFA rechazó el reclamo de la
federación francesa de fútbol por el gol
anulado Antoine griezmann en el partido
contra túnez la FIFA emitió un
comunicado en el que no explica la razón
de su decisión Francia reclamaba que el
árbitro había cantado el supuesto fuera
de juego Cuando el partido ya se había
reanudado Incluso se había dado Ya el
pitazo final
hasta aquí Diario del mundial los
invitamos a acompañarnos de nuevo mañana
con un especial con una nueva emisión de
este diario del mundial en octavos de
final Mientras tanto sigan con la
programación de France 24
[Música]